dr. Jonathan Hite is a professor of
business ethics at New York University's
Stern School of Business and author of
several books including the righteous
mind why good people are divided by
politics and religion as well as the
happiness hypothesis dr. heit welcome to
the show thank you Tim please call me
John John all right I will call you John
but I want to stress that you are a
professor at college in 2016 so first
off are you doing this from a bunker are
you secure and do people know where you
are do you have a panic room a safe room
how's it going I'm in a business school
so it's a sort of an island of
pragmatism in a larger sea of
politicization so I I'm okay I don't
worry about me that's well that is nice
to hear so we're gonna get to that
larger sea in a second but that's an
interesting distinction are you sort of
sheltered as a business person where you
guys are really looking at at numbers
all the time and really what actually
works and it's a way a little bit from
the social sciences which I love of
course but are you sheltered from some
of this stuff well yeah because the
craziness comes out of the humanities
originally its Gender Studies all the
ethnic studies programs as for a lot
Exedy has come from
so they've thoroughly taken over the
humanities the Natural Sciences are
largely untouched they're fine and in
the social sciences are in the middle
and that's how I got involved is I'm a
social psychologist and as these norms
as political correctness began warping
research into Social Sciences I started
getting more concerned yeah all right
well we're gonna die very deep into that
but let's let's talk a little bit about
some of your the stuff you've written
about in some of your research first so
you talk about emotions and morality a
lot and you've written about it a lot
and is morality is it quantifiable how
do you do this as as a professor as
someone that needs evidence how are you
able to quantify what morality actually
is so I've been studying moral
psychology since 1987 since I started
graduate school and my basic approach
has been to say this is an aspect of
human nature if you look around the
world people are sexual so you could
study sexuality people like music people
talk
could study linguistics well one thing
people do they judge others wherever you
go they gossip they criticize they gang
up they get angry that's what I said
you're just talking out twittered right
now right ha well actually that's right
you take all these ancient circuits that
we have for doing morality in small
tribal groups ad in social media and
it's like you inject you know speed and
cocaine and everything into our normal
circuits and that's part of what's
happened how do you make that
distinction then now that we live in a
time where everyone is constantly typing
and tweeting and texting and
snapchatting how do you separate what
sort of real versus what just exists in
that world I find it very hard to do
because you know what people will say to
my face about my show or what they think
of me is often very different than what
they might write in 140 characters yeah
well one of the one of the great
insights our metaphor I like to use is
from the matrix if you've seen any of
those movies ORS you know the matrix is
a consensual hallucination and that is a
great metaphor for social life all of
social life is a consensual
hallucination and so it's real but it's
not real in the way that rocks and trees
are real but if social media creates
this alternate universe that's real and
so part of what's happened is we evolved
to live in these small-scale societies
and now that we have all these tools
it's like we're suddenly getting hit
with these like levels of this fourth
and fifth dimension of social reality
and I think it's affecting young people
in particular in ways that we just don't
understand yeah you know I I did a video
a couple weeks ago about how we really
are becoming the matrix because we sort
of are the batteries for our little
devices now right I mean we're we're
almost living in a parallel society on
there yeah well that's right and so you
know as a social scientist I keep
reminding myself no matter how awful all
this stuff is in a sense the
universities are kind of burning
themselves down but I kind of sit here
and sometimes I think wow this is really
interesting professional point of view
right as the world burned certain people
have more value I guess or something
like that so as someone that studies
this stuff and writes about it
do you find it curious that we seem to
live in a time where we value emotion
more than fact when I say we I don't
mean the two of us but as a society at
least at the moment that seems to be
where we're at well um we all think that
we have reason on our side so I'm I'm
nan political I'm a centrist I used to
be on the Left once as I began studying
this stuff I sort of non-political I try
to understand everybody and one thing
that fascinates me is that when I talk
to groups on the right they say yeah but
you know sure all that stuff you say is
very interesting but isn't the bottom
line that our side is based on reason
and their side is all just based on
emotion when I talk to groups on the
left is exact same thing right reason
and the other side is emotional now my
research and a lot of people's research
these days is on what's called motivated
reasoning so we're all reasoning all the
time but that reasoning is sort of
constrained and pushed and shaped by not
just emotions it's sort of our
commitments our intuitions are group
identity so we're always reasoning we're
always having an emotion or emotions and
commitments and those are they're sort
of very interesting yeah so that's
interesting I know I know this about you
that you used to be on the left and now
you're would you say you're more a
political just by the definition of the
work that you do or do you really find
yourself a centrist in terms of what
your actual beliefs are well I for a
long time I hated the Republican Party
and I think that since Newt Gingrich
they have become a really irresponsible
party and so I I called myself somebody
who was in the center but I didn't like
the Republicans um I think the Democrats
are especially all this campus stuff
yeah they the federal government is now
telling universities you must prosecute
this and now with the bathroom stuff you
must have your I mean it's like so this
is actually kind of driving me a bit
more libertarian like you know what is
the urgent need of the day and right now
I think the urgent need of the day is
for central government to back off we
have so much diversity in this country
and if it's going to be that the federal
government gets to control things then
it's going to be a constant struggle to
gain control of the federal government
so our side can beat the hell out of the
other
yeah so all right so let's I wasn't I
wasn't planning on going there but let's
let's do this campus the campus bathroom
the North Carolina bathroom situation
for a moment because there's an element
of morality of wanting to treat people
equally and then I can actually
understand the concerns of some of the
people also if I had a five year old
daughter and you know just some random
man who said that he was a woman wanted
to go into the bathroom I could
understand that but our but the edict
from the from the federal government has
been you're gonna do this and you know
the NBA said they're not going to have
the all-star game down there unless they
go with this and you know you hear about
bands that won't play down there and all
this stuff meanwhile they'll play in
Russia and China and all kinds of other
places how does how does morality factor
into that and and the laws that we make
that's great so I don't want to talk
about the substance of it I want to get
into the details but bathroom policy but
it's a great example for us about the
way morality works so one of the three
principles of moral psychology that I
cover in my book the righteous mind is
morality binds and blinds so we we love
to identify something as a sacred value
sacred object like a rock or a tree
traditional religions would make a
person or a river something as sacred
and then we circle around it we worship
it we make sacrifices to it that's the
way religions have always worked well
now that religions are fading out but we
have these these sort of new or
moralistic religions and so you know
fighting race is very good cause well
when fighting racism becomes the center
of a religious cult you get all these
extreme policies and this is what
universities have been for several
decades they've been basically cults
devoted to fighting racism and again a
good aim but it has been warping
research right so the road to hell is
paved with good intentions
Zak so that's so sirs go with me here we
got like this like 40 50 year thing
about racism okay so then we have this
like 20 year thing about gay rights ok
marriage and everybody in universities
is totally in favor of gay rights gay
marriage that's been true for decades
and it's the most amazing thing that
American society just in about 20 years
we go from like no way never to
okay I guess it's the law of the land
and most people accept it so 20 years
that's amazing okay but now what's weird
is three years ago nobody knew a
transgender person nobody thought about
it did was on anybody's radar mm-hmm so
to make it in three years from that to
you must do this this I think is a
bridge too far and this I think is I
think Obama is going to be remembered
for this I think it's going to cause a
lot of reaction because the country was
not ready for this and it's not
appropriate for the federal government I
can see why the Supreme Court would
weigh in on marriage rights because
marriage has to be coordinated among the
states I get that
bathrooms the federal government
bathrooms like you know did nobody read
the Federalist Papers has nobody for the
Constitution like this is nuts right so
that gets to what you said earlier that
you take an issue that you can have some
moral debate about but then your
reaction is wait a minute I don't want
the government the federal government
coming in and telling what a state can
do in its bathroom and then it takes
someone like yourself and says well now
I'm gonna be more interested in
libertarianism because I want to the
government to back out of this that
that's really interesting that's right
oh and just to just I'm the reason I
brought that all up yeah to say the way
to understand what's going on to the
bathroom controversy is that as a
certain elements of the social justice
left have been victorious on certain
fronts um this is the newest
battleground and so this becomes an
object of sort of sacredness and extreme
devotion so the way to understand all
these moral movements is a kind of a
crusade that binds people together so
I'm at durkheimian that means that I
believe that emile durkheim the
sociologist is the greatest social
scientist who ever lived and Durkheim
taught us to see social action social
activities often as efforts to create
group solidarity to strengthen our team
so that we can fight that T and that I
think is what's happening a lot on
campus so that would describe what
people are saying is intersectionality
right we're sort of all these groups
kind of that have often very valid of
problems and they want to be heard where
they just sort of glob together and then
they become this sort of other monster
that nobody really intended right that's
right that's right and it has and and a
good a good moral and political movement
needs
good clear enemy so you must must
believe that the other side is really
strong and is adamant against you and
racism is everywhere sexism is
everywhere transphobia is everywhere
homophobia is everywhere so you need a
good solid enemy and even though
universities are the most anti-racist
anti-sexist country but it's an article
of faith that they are institutionally
racist institutionally sexist so it's an
incoherent movement if you look at from
the outside but psychologically it's
very standard sort of Manichaean
us-versus-them religion yeah what what
do you think it is about the human mind
that doesn't allow people a little space
to change so for example as you said the
transgender rights movement is happening
so fast right I'm obviously a hundred
percent for it I want these people to be
treated a hundred percent equally right
so I'm of course I'm for it but this
idea that if you aren't completely on
board the way you want to be they want
you to be on board that's suddenly
you're transphobic or even you know look
seven years ago Barack Obama wasn't for
gay marriage was he a homophobe seven
years ago I mean that's just silly so
what is it about human psychology that
doesn't allow it seems like a certain
subset of people the second they make a
decision everyone has to evolve with
them at the exact same time right
because we evolved in small tribes we
evolved so the one of the wisest dictums
or cultural sayings is the Bedouin
proverb me against my brother he and my
brother against our cousin me my brother
and cousin against the stranger so we're
very good at making these recursive like
you know with this group against that
group and so what's happening and we
maybe we can get into this this or the
idea of victimhood culture yeah what's
happening is a kind of a moral movement
on campus we are sort of a sort of the
social justice left and you find this on
every campus you find a group don't film
eat though
they'll often take gender studies
courses and intersectionality stuff all
that stuff so you'll have a group which
is very much in an us-versus-them
mindset and everybody on every side
thinks that they're the victim that's
what's so interesting here right they
may think they're actually I mean
there's a list where someone's got to
have the list right do you have the list
of just who's in who where in the
pecking order oh yeah
there's the biggest of their seven so
there's the big three which is where
almost all the controversies almost all
the stuff on campus is about so it's
African Americans women & LGBT so that's
what almost everything is on campus and
then there's what you might call the
little three not that they're small but
just they're less prominent and that is
a Latino handicapped of any kind and
Native Americans those are the six that
have been around for a few decades yeah
just in the last year its Muslims so the
left so this is very alarming to me I
mean I'm Jewish and suddenly to see you
know Jews are oppressors Jews are evil
so there's a lot of sympathy on the left
so in Europe the left is very very Pro
Palestinian and certainly anti Zionist
and sometimes anti-semitic and until a
year ago I I was thinking you know well
America is different but it's getting
much more like Europe right so I mean I
see articles about this constantly so
what is it then Jews are obviously a
minority 1% of the United States
basically there's only about 15 million
Jews I think that might be on the high
side in the entire world
how did they get booted out of the
oppression Olympics um so it um there
are these ideas it comes originally from
Marxism and developed by Herbert Marcuse
and others the whole idea of privilege
the idea that some groups are privileged
and so there's a way of looking at the
world in which you start by saying
what's your what's your group or your
class and if you're high you're the bad
people and if you're low you're the good
and so that's exactly what Mao's
Cultural Revolution was all about there
are the classes which are the peasants
and there's a bad class of which are the
educated classes and you don't go out
and kill the good classes automatically
but they're under suspicion constant or
suspicion they don't get to speak and
there's a lot of a lot of writing and
leftist circles about this and and so
when you start that way it progressed it
just predictably is going to go into
constant splitting and civil war and
chaos so that's what happens to leftist
movements they eat their own that was
that was the jacobins in France after
the Revolution and that's what we're
seeing I think happened on on campus now
we're seeing battles between feminists
between splinter groups
um and if you think about it this what's
so infuriating you know you're on a
campus you try to make arguments you try
to use reasons you meet students the
very first thing they do is they size
you up
what's your race what's your gender I'm
judging you on the basis of that I'm not
even listen I'm not listening to you
you're a bad person based on your race
and gender like really
your whole worldview is you start by
saying some people are good at bad
because the race do you know what you
sound like
right they sound like maybe that was
they should have been mainstreamed 50
years ago but certainly not now you know
if you want to create a social movement
a social revolution like be the change
you seek you know if you want to stop
racism and sexism then don't be hyper
racist and sexist perfect it's that
that's not rocket science um so what
about the professor's I know you can't
speak for all the professors that all
the universities all over the all over
the place but everyone sees this thing
happening we see it every day a
different school with another one of
these incidences our professors talking
about this stuff or is there any
movement by faculty to fight it I mean
what's going on there so this has been
really fascinating this is um
so here's the situation um the
professorial has leaned left certainly
since the Progressive Era and in the
twentieth century I've been collecting
data on this me and my colleagues in the
twentieth century it was basically two
to one or three to one left to right and
that's fine you can funk you know we
don't care about about equality we just
the key thing is what's called a
institutionalized disconfirmation if
somebody says something that has to be
somebody another side is because they
wait a second that makes no sense so
that's the way it always was the 20th
century right so two to one you're okay
with that ratio oh my god we could get
four to one I would right it's not it's
closer to what five to one now or
something
oh it's seven to one overall but that
I'm sorry five or six to one overall but
almost all the conservatives are in
engineering schools business schools if
you look at the core areas of the
university so this is the humanities and
Social Sciences it's ten to one or
twenty to one Wow and once that happens
the few that are not on the Left go into
the closet so the key thing that
everyone needs to keep in mind is that
almost all professors are on the left
but they're not a liberal so you've got
the key thing to keep in mind is what's
happened here is the illiberal left I
guess you call it the regressive left
I'll go with the liberal for our
purposes the liberal left is a small you
know not tiny but it's a small portion
and then the liberal left because
liberals traditionally believed in
freedom freedom of speech freedom of
thought
so the illiberal left has everybody else
scared it's the students overwhelmingly
because the students everyone if it was
afraid of the students the students were
afraid of the students professors are
created the students so the illiberal
left make these demands they march into
the president's office they demand this
and that they accuse everybody of racism
and sexism and because everybody's on
the left and everyone is afraid of the
students nobody stands up so when the
Christakis is at yale when stock you
know so within three days there was a
giant petition 500 Yale professors
backing the students well I had one of
my research assistants find out what
departments they're all in it was Gender
Studies film studies English was that
stuff so the humanities are like they're
totally on board with us the humanities
are full of illiberal leftists um four
weeks later a small petition forty names
mostly stem mostly scientists so the
natural scientists are still liberals
this they they believe in openness they
believe in debate so that's what you
have to keep in mind it the problem
comes out of the humanities the Social
Sciences are in the middle and the
question is where do we where does the
liberal left have such dominance that
the professors are afraid to speak and I
started a group called heterodox Academy
Nia neva professor and if Rosencrantz um
we got together and we realized we got
the same problems in our field and so we
just started getting together people who
are willing to say something about it
and it's been thrilling because we're
right people if you're listening please
go to heterodox academy org we've been
writing we've been talking about this
and nobody's objecting like nobody is
saying we're bad people
nobody's saying we're wrong because
professors are largely afraid and a lot
of are thrilled that we're speaking up
right you don't think there's a listserv
somewhere I know you guys love the
listservs right is you don't think
there's one somewhere going I that
I know oh there probably is but they
haven't been anything publicly I mean I
do Google searches I'm keep looking for
someone who's gonna criticize right well
that's that's actually it's nice to get
some some good news out of this do you
think do you think there's I'll go ahead
no I'm just gonna say I think what we're
in is the emperor's new clothes we're a
small group has is saying you know oh
everything is racist and sexist and we
need to do all these things and most
people are kind of uncomfortable with
this but they're not speaking up but
outside the university everyone thinks
they're crazy and inside the university
a lot of people think that the
protestors are extremists but they're
afraid to speak up but gradually as more
and more than get attacked and almost
everybody's getting attacked at some
point as more and more of them get
attacked they come to us so are we
winning then even though it doesn't
really feel like it at the sense that I
get from you is actually pretty hopeful
that there's something changing right
now yes I guess so I think that um the
this was a kind of a revolution that
went way too far and again you know as
you've said you know you and I I mean
we're both in favor of gay rights we
don't want black students to feel
unwelcome and so we're very sympathetic
to the to the complaints into the the
problems it's a question of what are the
proper methods and the methods that the
students have demanded more social
justice training more biased reporting
systems anonymous reporting systems
diversity training these things are
going to make things so much worse
um and what I'm really encouraged by is
this outside the university everyone
thinks they're crazy and so the first
university presidents who just caved in
so Peter Salovey at Yale Christina
Paxson at Brown the first University
presidents were faced with a mob of
angry students and who said you know oh
you're right we're so racist if you know
who's racist Brown is just oh my god
here we have fifty million dollars Peter
salivation
question hundred million dollars for
diversity so the first presidents did
that what happens the alumni are like
what are you doing what are you doing
with our no you know we're not giving
you any more and missouri's you know
things are way down it is or they're in
big trouble yeah the first presidents
all caved in but then they started
hearing from alumni they were there
laughing stocks there everyone's making
fun of them um and so now we're seeing
some presidents willing to stand up
because they know that if they cave in
they're gonna be made fun of forever and
they care about their legacy so the
greatest one you don't hear about the
way I Oh state that was really thrilling
you know about this one which what is
this there's so many I'll have to go
through my file which one so the first
real some so in Ohio State the student
protesters they came charging into
administration building and they were
chanting and shouting and occupied hear
our demands and we demand to see the
president we demand you know here's our
all tomato and so the president sends an
envoy who says um if you're here to give
the president mel tomato he will never
meet with you he will not accept an
ultimate you want to come talk to him
some other time please schedule a visit
he'd be glad to talk now when you came
into this building you made everyone
feel afraid this is an office building
and the workers in this building felt
afraid he was brilliant they were using
the whole language of safety against the
protesters Wow so you made them feel
afraid they've all gone home now they're
coming to work tomorrow morning and they
have to have a safe place to stuff at
five o'clock the kemp's police are going
to come in and arrest anyone who's still
here we will give you a chance to go to
jail for your convictions if you're
still here you will be arrested and
expelled from Ohio State good day oh my
god it was just you people should just
look up the video just Ohio State
student protesters yeah and did they so
I assume they left and then what
happened after that they left yeah
that's right they left and now
everybody's praising that president and
nothing bad happened to him as far as I
know so I think we've turned a corner
presidents aren't gonna just lie down
and get anymore that's one alumni are
mad as hell they're saying we're not
giving if you do this because we believe
in free speech and you wouldn't want to
turn it into a left-wing propaganda
Factory and I think we're going to see
more students rising up we're not seeing
that yet I mean they're conservative
groups on each campus but even they are
often afraid to speak but I think next
year we're going to see a lot more
students standing up alumni standing up
so I think the tide is turning yeah so
do you think it is the best way to
decouple people from these bad ideas
exactly that what that president did
because I get people emailing me all the
time that say they hear the things we're
talking about on this show and you know
they'll post something a video of ours
or something and then they say then I a
medium in a fight with my brother and my
cousin hates me and this one blocked me
and telling me I'm a racist and a bigot
and all this stuff and they always
asking me for advice on how to engage
with these people so would you say that
really is the best way to do it what's
right so uh you know when when you are
the first people to stand up and like a
video that is critical to protesters
yeah you're going to hear from your
Facebook Network and that's what keeps
people down but probably the majority of
people are at least freaked out by this
a little bit so I think things are going
to change when the younger when the high
school kids now it's we're in high
school now when they join in and
laughing at these silly campus
snowflakes that students who are afraid
to see a photograph or to hear a word
when so a mockery and humor is actually
the way that honor revolutions happen um
Macha so keep up the mockery and humor I
say good good work I know we need George
Carlin back as I think every morning
when I wake up if only George Carlin was
around for this so some of this I think
is coupled to human happiness which is
another thing that you talk about a lot
and basically you say that when humans
aren't only doing things for themselves
they actually are measurably happier did
I say that correctly so so interestingly
a lot of these movements there's this
idea that if you're doing good for other
people that somehow you'll be happier
but in a weird way that doesn't even
really add up right well it does in a
funny way so in general people need a
sense of meaning and purpose in their
lives and young people are really
looking for it so I went to Yale
undergrad and we all join protests
against apartheid and you know that was
a big cause was fighting apartheid so we
were all united in fighting a faraway
evil and that brought us together made
us feel that we were doing something
important oh sorry
so idea they're shutting the power down
on you shut me down okay so that wasn't
very destructive yeah but you know the
world's a much more just place than it
was in the 1980s and university camps
are much more just and open than they
were
teenage does not a lot to protest so the
movements now are so there's what's
called concept Creek so the standard for
what counts as a violations gotten so
low that everybody is violating it every
day
and so this joins people together to
fight each other and their local
community and it colleges doesn't look
like it's any fun anymore I mean you
just basically you're walking on
eggshells everyone is attacking everyone
so it's are they not smoking enough weed
am i that long out of college
it hasn't been that long but it seems
like they're not smoking enough weed
anymore yeah well I'd say weed xanax and
uh uh let's see what else
yeah that's those two that would do it
you